adler haaretz aktuelle ausstellung in
zürich heisst nach strich und faden und
macht klar sehen ist hier eine leise
aber politische form des protests ihre
arbeiten sind nie harmlos klar es zieht
ihre fäden und brüchiges oder versehrte
zu zeigen
etwa wenn sie kleider zu hängenden engen
therapiert und mit venen versieht
himmlisches wird verletzlich und so auf
die erde geholt
die hölle auf erden thematisiert sie
dagegen in ihrem neuesten werk mit dem
titel mediterraneum mittelmeer
haaretz stellt ein foto von anfang 1900
ins zentrum mit migranten auf dem weg
ins ungewisse
das foto ergänzt sie mit stoff
einem roten schleier für drei frauen die
das schicksal gleichsam auf ihren
schultern tragen die frauen gehen in
eine situation wo sie nicht wie es
einmal besser haben einfach mut und
kraft das zu tun und vielleicht es ist
wie eine darstellung dass zukunft in die
arbeiten fließen eindrücke ein die
haaretz auf ihren reisen durch die welt
gesammelt hat in afrika alles china oder
indien wo sie sich für frauenrechte
einsetzt
jetzt ist sie zurückgezogen in ihr
heimatdorf im tessin und erinnert sich
wie alles begann
und es hat mich sehr tief beeindruckt
und das war auch sehr hart aber dann das
hat mich schon ein bisschen gehe also
total geändert weil ich habe sehr
schwierige situation gesehen und das
sieht man nicht in der schweiz und man
sieht es ist eben das wert ist groß und
es gibt andere sachen
bald darauf fängt sie an
zeitungsausschnitte über katastrophen
mit fäden weiter zu zeichnen
der weiche stoff kontrastiert die harten
meldung und macht das elend damit umso
deutlicher
es ist wichtig dass man ein bisschen an
die diese sache die nicht so bequem sind
berührt das ist nicht das ist nicht
interessant zum reden so ist das wetter
so das ist wichtig denn am punkt kommen
direkt wo sie die leute irgendwas zu
sagen haben
mit der nähmaschine zeichnet die
37-jährige die schicksale der nach die
etwas zu erzählen haben aber oft nicht
zu wort kommen etwa frauen im arabischen
raum im projekt ein breiteres auf
aktuelle die stickerinnen der
wirklichkeit lässt sie syrische
flüchtlingsfrauen selbstportraits
sticken und gleichzeitig ihre
lebensgeschichten erzählen
diese zeit wird er von word erfüllt und
würden wir in einen kaffee sein das ist
nicht dasselbe weil der sticken das ist
schon ein aktivität und dann fließt
einfach die hin
das gespräch sehr viel einfacher die
künstlerin gibt so denn syrien die sonst
verborgen und stumm blieben gesicht und
stimme
die tragen ihre schicksale erscheinen
gedruckt auf den porträts auch
sexualität ist kein tabu erkläre haaretz
lässt marokkanerinnen abbilder von
jungfernhäutchen nähen und auf eine
typische amerikanische frauen unter hose
stecken die frauen die umrisse von
marokko als wäre es das blut der
entjungferung dabei kommt viel leid zur
sprache
diese erfahrung weiter gezeigt wird und
weitere erzählt wird weil es ist eine
wichtige situation hat neuer harz ist
sich bewusst dass sie mit ihrer leisen
kunst nur eine geringe wirkung erzielt
aber so sagt sich selber wenn es gelinge
anderen ein wenig die augen zu öffnen
für das elend in der welt
dann sei schon viel gewonnen